cinq ans plus tard la fiche est la même
emmanuel macron et marine le pen se
retrouve de nouveau face à face dans les
yvelines c'est le rassemblement national
la gagne un petit point au premier tour
de la présidentielle par rapport à 2010
est dans les communes rurales situées au
nord du département et à l'extrême sud
les résultats sont en hausse par exemple
à guîtres en cours marine le pen arrive
en tête avec 39 67 % des suffrages c'est
quatre points de plus qu'en 2017 moi je
suis adhérent j'ai été chez marine le
pen il ya longtemps en 2008 et donc du
coup
j'aimerais bien que marine le pen un
jour elle passe mais moi je pense
qu'elle passera jamais par contre marion
maréchal elle passera donc dix quinze
vingt ans ça arrivera mais à la france
ça sera descendu bien bas j'ai voté pour
marine le pen parce que l ai pas je ses
idées sont assez proches des miennes je
pense qu'elle veut redonner un petit peu
de pouvoir d'achat aux gens donc ça ça
me paraît important
elle est allée contre l'immigration je
partage un petit peu ses idées je trouve
que voilà on a suffisamment ici en
france certains yvelinois attendent
encore le débat de l'entre-deux tours
pour se décider d'autres ont déjà fait
leur choix ce sera marine le pen pour
contrer emmanuel macron marine le pen
parce que je ne crois pas en ma
compassion sa politique la politique me
dérange c'est un personnage qui est
détestable pour moi j'attends le débat
parce que monsieur macro on va nous
présenter pour voir ce qui va défendre
et madame le pen savoir si elle va mieux
se débrouiller qu' il ya cinq ans
monsieur macron il veut détruire la
france il veut détruire les petits
villages il veut détruire les
départements et il veut détruire la
france et pour l'europe qu'il agit si le
rassemblement national progresse dans
les yvelines avec plus de 3000 suffrages
supplémentaires par rapport à 2010 est
sa candidate n'arrive en tête que dans
quarante et une des communes contre 56
il ya cinq ans